[Música]
estas son las noticias de france 24 fue
sentenciado a 41 meses de prisión jake
hopkins ley conocido como el chamán de
crandon por su participación en la toma
del edificio del capitolio la sede del
congreso de eeuu durante una sesión en
la que los legisladores certificaban la
victoria de joe biden frente a donald
trump
y siguen llegando a la frontera polaco
bielorrusa más migrantes donde aguardan
para continuar hacia territorio de la
unión europea principalmente alemania
precisamente los líderes de la unión
europea buscan facilitar el retorno de
los migrantes a sus países de origen una
propuesta que no solucionaría el tema de
raíz
y sudán vivió el día más mortífero desde
el golpe de estado del 25 de octubre al
menos 15 personas murieron por la
represión en una nueva jornada de
protestas contra la junta militar que
tomó el poder el comité central de
médicos denunció que la policía intentó
allanar varios hospitales donde hay
manifestantes heridos
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 estamos en vivo
desde nuestros estudios en bogotá en
colombia soy santiago lópez gonzález
vamos a comenzar en eeuu allí jake of
shankly conocido como el chamán de qua
non' por su participación en el asalto
al capitolio el pasado 6 de enero fue
condenado a 41 meses de prisión por el
tribunal federal de los eeuu el hombre
fue detenido después de estos hechos
ocurridos en la ciudad de washington
este juicio hace parte de los más de 700
casos criminales ligados al asalto del
capitolio más detalles en el siguiente
informe
conocido por su sombrero con cuernos y
apodado como el chamán qua non' por la
teoría de la conspiración de extrema
derecha que apoya una que presenta a
donald trump como salvador y a los
dirigentes demócratas como una cábala
satánica jacov chang lee de 34 años fue
uno de los primeros manifestantes en
entrar al capitolio el 6 de enero y se
convirtió en una de las caras más
reconocidas entre los seguidores de
trump que asaltaron el capitolio tras un
discurso del entonces presidente en el
que reclamaba sin fundamentos que perdió
la elección como resultado de un fraude
electoral
este año los demócratas llevaron a cabo
el robo electoral más descarado y
escandaloso y nunca existió nada como
esto es un auténtico robo en la historia
estadounidense
af el merkén es ser barinas sin camiseta
y lanza en mano chang lee entró en la
cámara del senado mientras el entonces
vice presidente mike pence presidía el
orden del día cuatro personas murieron
por la violencia desatada el 6 de enero
y más de 100 policía resultado en
heridos un oficial de la policía del
capitolio atacado por los manifestantes
falleció también al día siguiente la
cámara de representantes inició un
proceso de destitución impeachment
contra donald trump por incitar a la
revuelta si bien fue absuelto
posteriormente en el senado
charly cuya imagen se volvió viral en
redes sociales fue detenido sin fianza
tras su arresto en enero en septiembre
se declaró culpable de un único cargo
obstrucción a una sesión del congreso
apuntó estar decepcionado con donald
trump por no haberle insultado antes de
salir de la casa blanca' en su detención
fue diagnosticado con esquizofrenia
transitoria desorden bipolar depresión y
ansiedad su sentencia a 41 meses de
prisión llega el mismo día que scott
ferland ciudadano de new yersey recibió
la misma sentencia por su participación
en la revuelta hay cerca de 700 casos
criminales ligados al asalto al
capitolio nos vamos ahora hasta el este
de europa la frontera entre polonia y
belarús o para hacer de frente allí a la
crisis los líderes
de la unión europea contemplan facilitar
el retorno de los migrantes que se estan
aglomerando allí su retorno a los países
de procedencia aunque las conversaciones
están avanzando la propuesta no
solucionaría el origen de los problemas
que llevaron a estas personas a
abandonar sus países andrés granadillo
tiene los detalles
un momento de celebración en medio de la
crisis humanitaria los migrantes que
acampan en la frontera entre belarús y
polonia recibieron esperanzados la
noticia de la llamada telefónica entre
la canciller angela merkel y el
presidente alexander lukashenko la
segunda en menos de una semana
merkel sugirió que se facilite el
retorno de los migrantes a sus países de
origen a través de acnur y la
organización internacional para las
migraciones pero esta no es una opción
para muchos
a su vez calma ahora volver es difícil
ya que es como si no tuviéramos patria
se ha ido un sirio kurdo esperanza mente
por ver a sus padres quienes por décima
vez intentan llegar a europa 2 tú ves
hasta soy un fan de kilómetros estoy a
25 kilómetros de mis padres pero no
puedo ir a verlos llamarlos por teléfono
es muy duro unir en barca knicks este
sentimiento nos explica que su familia
termino separada en la frontera su madre
logró cruzar hacia polonia pero su padre
fue devuelto al otro lado
mientras cientos de ellos expuestos a un
clima extremo fueron conducidos a una
bodega con calefacción para pasar la
noche la crisis en la frontera que
inició el 8 de noviembre estatizada por
las críticas a minsk de supuestamente
atraer migrantes para que ingresen a la
unión europea a través de la frontera
con polonia los países del bloque dicen
que el gobierno de lukashenko no utiliza
esta táctica para castigar a europa por
las sanciones impuestas contra belarús
pese a los múltiples anuncios de
sanciones personas que huyen de la
guerra de sus países llegan a esta
gélida frontera con la esperanza de
iniciar una nueva vida en la unión
europea
y al sur de europa también continúan
llegando inmigrantes en italia un barco
afiliado a médicos sin fronteras se
encontró en aguas del mediterráneo una
embarcación con 99 personas a bordo el
rescate tuvo lugar muy cerca de las
costas de libia en el norte de áfrica en
la misma embarcación que estuvo a la
deriva por unas 13 horas fueron
encontrados también 10 cuerpos sin vida
según esta organización de médicos sin
fronteras unas mil 225 personas han
perdido la vida en su intento por cruzar
el mediterráneo tratando de alcanzar
territorio de la unión europea
y la situación epidemiológica en europa
sigue empeorando la organización mundial
de la salud indicó que este continente
es el único donde ha aumentado el número
de muertes por kobe 19 en la última
semana alva santana tiene los detalles
vuelven a sonar las alarmas por el
hobbit 19 en europa ya que según la oms
ese es el único continente del mundo en
el que están aumentando las muertes por
el virus con un incremento del 5 por
ciento en la última semana en alemania
con la tasa de incidencia y la ocupación
de las unidades de cuidados intensivos
al alza el gobierno de angela merkel
advirtió de la gravedad de la situación
y la situación actual de la pandemia es
dramática no puedo decirlo de otra
manera la cuarta ola golpeó en nuestro
país con toda su fuerza y aunque no hay
más fundamento legal para la situación
de emergencia nacional pandémica no
tengo ninguna duda que nos encontramos
en medio de tal situación de emergencia
en francia han optado por pedir a las
empresas que impulsen el teletrabajo y a
pesar de mostrarse optimista el
ejecutivo galo no descarta aplicar
medidas si es necesario
y yo sigo siendo cautelosamente
optimista y repito cautelosamente
optimista los datos y los modelos que
tenemos el instituto pasteur muestran
que con el nivel actual de vacunación
probablemente tenemos las herramientas
para limitar el impacto de la quinta ola
de rifas
mientras que en austria siguen
registrando récord de casos a pesar de
la imposición del confinamiento para los
no vacunados desde el lunes una polémica
medida que se está debatiendo en toda
europa por lo que denuncian es una
restricción de libertades y para algunos
su cuestionada efectividad
no se puede diferenciar a las personas
de esa manera crear dos clases sociales
creo deberíamos volver a un cierre total
y que eso no es factible
si la situación no mejora ms y ha
advertido que el continente podría
llegar a sumar 500.000 muertes más por
el virus hasta febrero
en sudán en áfrica al menos 14 personas
murieron en una nueva serie de
manifestaciones contra el golpe militar
la jornada ya fue considerada como la
más mortífera desde la toma del poder
por parte de los militares
en estas imágenes los manifestantes son
disparados con munición real una nueva
jornada de movilización en sudán se
cerró con varios muertos y heridos a
pesar de la represión y los gases
lacrimógeno es la resistencia contra el
golpe de estado del 25 de octubre no se
debilita semana tras semana de dar lo
que tenía esos jóvenes sueñan con un
gobierno civil de paz libertad justicia
y desarrollo nosotros somos personas
mayores sin futuro pero las demandas de
esos jóvenes deben ser atendidas a dogma
para luego la fecha del 17 de noviembre
es simbólica ese día la presidencia del
consejo de soberanía debería haber
pasado a manos de un gobierno civil sin
embargo hace un mes el golpe de estado
del general abdel fattah albur han hecho
por tierra esa esperanza y puso fin al
proceso de transición donde el poder se
repartía entre civiles y militares una
situación que la comunidad internacional
de flora como mencionó el secretario de
estado de eeuu antonio durante su visita
a kenia
sudán estaba en el camino hacia la
democracia y la estabilidad volver a esa
vía es la mejor manera de que sudán
logre la paz y la prosperidad se
convierta en un líder en el continente y
recupere el firme apoyo de la comunidad
internacional se espera que las
manifestaciones continúen en los
próximos días y en argentina- fue
celebrado el día de la militancia
peronista este año las movilizaciones
que fueron convocadas por el oficialismo
estuvieron marcadas por el resultado de
las recientes elecciones parlamentarias
en las que la coalición peronista perdió
la mayoría del senado el mismo
presidente de la nación alberto
fernández hizo un llamado para llenar la
plaza de mayo en el centro de buenos
aires para celebrar lo que el mandatario
ha considerado como un triunfo para su
coalición conocida como frente de todos
esto a pesar de haber perdido la mayoría
en el senado quedarse sin el control del
congreso y haber perdido también en la
mayoría de las provincias argentinas
nuestro corresponsal en buenos aires-
natalio cos hoy nos amplía más desde la
capital argentina
decenas de miles de simpatizantes y
seguidores del peronismo en argentina en
su mayoría de movimientos sindicales
afines al gobierno de movimientos
sociales de militantes por supuesto en
frente de todos de la coalición de
gobierno se reunieron aquí en la plaza
de mayo para celebrar el día del
militante peronista que recuerda el
regreso de juan domingo perón al país en
1972 luego de 20 años casi de exilio y
proscripción pero este es un día del
militante en particular porque se
celebra tres días después de las
elecciones legislativas en las que el
gobierno sufrió importantes rehn
derrotas en muchas partes del país sin
embargo el presidente alberto fernández
llamó a celebrar la victoria este día
aquí en todo caso si es una importante
demostración de fuerza en la calle la
fuerza que no pudiera obtener en las
urnas de cara por su por un lado las
negociaciones por el fondo monetario
internacional para renegociar una deuda
de casi 45 mil millones de dólares y
también para negociar con la oposición
en un congreso del que ya no tendrá
hegemonía nos vamos ahora hasta el
continente asiático en nueva delhi la
capital de la india la crítica situación
de la contaminación ha llevado a las
autoridades locales a suspender de
manera indefinida las clases en las
escuelas también como medida para
mitigar el deterioro deterioro ambiental
el gobierno local ordenó el cierre de
las empresas que funcionan a través de
la quema de carbón así como la
suspensión del transporte no esencial
con camiones las complejas condiciones
ambientales de la capital india ya han
puesto sobre alerta a la red
hospitalaria hwan pupiales nos cuenta
más
son víctimas del impacto de la
contaminación en ese hospital pediátrico
de nueva delhi denuncian que las
afectaciones respiratorias se han
triplicado entre los últimos 7 y 10 días
esto está directamente relacionado con
los altos niveles de contaminación de
los que estamos siendo testigos en la
ciudad de delhi y en la región capital
nacional
durante las últimas jornadas el índice
de calidad de aire de la ciudad ha
estado por encima de 451 en una escala
de 500 algo que se traduce en una
situación grave por una orden de la
comisión de la ciudad para la calidad
del aire se extendió de manera
indefinida al cierre de las escuelas así
como la suspensión en al menos cinco de
las 11 fábricas que funcionan con carbón
también se prohibió el tránsito de los
camiones que no sean esenciales además
se dio la orden de enviar a teletrabajo
a la mitad de los funcionarios medidas
que cuestionan algunos expertos en las
medidas de emergencia aunque sean muy
drásticas no son medidas fáciles y
convenientes para aplicar
se hacen solamente para asegurar que la
situación no empeore por decisión esta
polución impulsada sobre todo por la
contaminación industrial la quema de
cultivos estacional y la bajada de las
temperaturas es regional la vecina
ciudad del ajo en pakistán también vive
una crisis ambiental por estas fechas
con niveles de partículas de
contaminación 8 veces superiores a lo
recomendado en delhi ya hay una amenaza
de confinamiento por contaminación a
pedido de la corte suprema del país
y ahora demos un vistazo a lo que
tenemos publicado en nuestra página web
france24 punto coma hasta ahora tenemos
en portada merkel educación que acuerda
en diálogo para resolver la crisis
fronteriza en la unión europea tema que
también destacamos en esta emisión de
noticias también encuentran ustedes el
minuto minutos de otras noticias
destacadas de la jornada
y con esto ponemos punto final a las
noticias en france 24 siga con nosotros
[Música]